if you just started a business you just
became an entrepreneur you just got into
a new industry or maybe you just got
into sales and you're about to throw in
the towel because nothing seems to go
your way
today's messages for you let me explain
to what happened to me yesterday
yesterday my eight-year-old son's friend
has a birthday at this place called the
ninja warrior place strong warrior place
so my wife and our three kids go to this
place and it's a nice place it's got a
gym on one side and in the back it has
the whole obstacle course for the kids
and then there's the adult section where
they do tournaments so by the time my
kids were kind of done doing their thing
and they're kind of having fun and they
found their friends I started kind of
adventuring and finding out what they
have at this place so I go to the gym
they have the pull-up bar they have the
ropes and then all of a sudden I see
these walls that I've seen before you
know these they call them the Warped
wall right they use them in these Ninja
Warrior stuff so I look and I'm like how
tall is this one 10 feet okay I think I
can do this one so I run up and I make
it I come down then I walk and I see a
couple other things and I see these two
walls one is green one is blue I look at
the Gandhi instruct on like let me ask a
question how tall is that one that one's
12 feet how about this one that's
massive oh that's a tournament one
that's 14 feet 14 feet that's what they
use a ninja warrior tournaments that's
14 feet 14 feet yes it looks like the
Wall of China when you look at it right
so let me give a shot with the 12-foot
one I look at it I'm going going going
hesitating coming back finally I run I
make the 12-footer I come back down then
I'm looking at the 14-foot wall and when
you look at this blue wall it just looks
impossible especially if you've never
done it before I'm not a CrossFit guy
I'm not a ninja warrior guy lift weights
I do cardio that's pretty much what I
doing some other exercises that I do
boxing and fighting right so I'm
watching this thing and right before I'm
testing this out I'm kind of doing some
steps and I'm hesitating a little bit
one father comes and he's like yeah let
me do this his wife and kids or their
wife starts recording he runs up he
falls on his back so bad it was
embarrassing his kids are there people
are watching it was terrible so I'm
standing in front of this thing thinking
the same thing is gonna happen to me as
this father that just happened my wife
is are watching this
she's been recording for 10 minutes
because I said record I'm gonna try to
make this thing here ten minutes later
my wife leaves because like baby I got
to go see where the kids are on my wife
leaves okay she comes back she says what
are you doing they announced their call
the gym down the birthday is over with
you guys got to leave and I'm telling
the guys I gotta try this thing because
if I go home tonight without at least
trying to give my best for this thing
and knowing that my best isn't good
enough to go up there I can't go to
sleep but I have to at least one that I
give my best so another 20 minutes goes
the guy's like listen we're closing up
the gym I said just let me so my wife
starts recording then I run up I don't
make it I run up I don't make it I run
up I don't make it a couple times I
hesitate finally he comes up he whispers
to me says listen can I just give you
some counsel I said yes
nice 28 year old guy 29 year old guy he
says if I can just be honest with you
you're not committed to this jump the
only way this jump is gonna work out for
you is you have to be totally committed
I said what do you mean I was almost
like a little bit offended by this is
you're not committed to this jump but
he's saying it to me with a smile on his
face very respectful I said tell me why
he says every time you jump your left
hand hits the wall and the reason why
you're doing that is because you're
scared that you're not gonna make it in
your mind you're already coming down
because you're trying to protect
yourself you think you're gonna hit the
wall he says the only way this works is
you have to run up and then your hands
have to go like this you're not doing
that you're going like this so I said
okay let me see what's gonna happen this
time so I start looking at the wall and
I'm asking myself are you really fully
committed to this what's the worst thing
that's gonna happen worst thing that's
gonna happen is you're gonna fall like
that father maybe a little bit more
because you're 20 pounds heavier than
him so it could be a little bit worse
than that but that's the worst thing
that's gonna happen okay no problem I'm
fully committed go for it and I take the
steps in all of sudden I jump up and I
make it once I'm up there I pull myself
up I hit the board because I'm excited I
come down my daughter comes I pick her
up I'm my wife is saying so you want to
say anything I said prior to me doing
this I did this many times so I'm late
and I'm sweating I'm sweating I did it
twice just to know that I didn't get
lucky why am i sharing this story with
let me tell you why I'm sharing this
story with you look I know a lot of
people that I advise that run businesses
they get into sales for the first time
or they're entrepreneurs or they put
some money into their business and it
doesn't work out for them and they fail
miserably they blame the industry they
blame everything but they don't look
back and ask themselves the one question
before you throw in the towel did you
ever fully commit to making this
business work
let me explain to what I mean by this
did you fully commit to the jump or did
the wall of china scare you because
that's what it looked like looked like a
wall of china you have your own wall of
china when you're going up in your
business you don't know if you can do
the business you're afraid what if this
doesn't work out what if you lose the
money what if your friends your peers
people tell you I knew you could never
be an entrepreneur you could never make
it in real estate you thought you can go
into cells and make this a you can't you
can't get into financial industry I knew
you couldn't do it and that's in the
backyard and in the backyard you were
saying worst case scenario I'm gonna go
back to what I was doing you're not
committed so whatever you're doing right
now
whatever you doing right now if you're
not going to commit stop doing it if
you're willing to commit and know that
there may be some consequences then go
for it one doesn't go without the other
by the way this applies to every aspect
of your life family parenting marriage
relationship finance getting into shape
so whatever you got going on I know this
is maybe not the news you wanted to hear
today because you were hoping I could
give you an out moving forward this week
today starting today if you're in after
watching this video fully commit
assuming everything's gonna go your way
even if it doesn't the chances you make
in it doesn't just go up 10% 20% 50%
your chances goes up dramatically 80 90
% if you fully commit to making it work
and if you do that 3 6 12 24 months from
now when people ask you what happened
all of a sudden you were about to caught
a business you just made a million
dollars you're netting a half a million
dollars look at the life you're
traveling all over the world
what happened to this lifestyle you got
everybody wants to know what you're
doing with your life
in the back your money gonna say man two
years ago if you only know how scared I
was and how much I was hesitating I
finally totally committed and this
happened to my life so I'm hoping you
take up my challenge today and go fully
commit to whatever business whatever
venture whatever industry you just got
involved in and watch the magic happen
to you having said that have a killer
week everybody take care
buh bye
you
[Music]